en plus l'ambiance j'ai subissait déjà
avant marie claveau mon coming out mais
je pense que cette le fait que je lui
raconte que je dise
que je suis gay salua du noir est ce que
tu peux parler bien force comme avec le
masque voilà je merci comme avant j'ai
su me suis mis c'est déjà pas mal de
violence ouais lumière lui racontant du
coup que je suis dit ça lui a permis ça
lui a donné une raison plus et ça ici de
s'en prendre à moi et pour l'histoire de
mon oncle je pense que c'est que ce que
je me rappellerai toute ma vie est
clairement c'est j'avais mon en crise et
qui était mis sur moi la seule personne
qui était là pour séparer parce que je
n'avais vraiment pas la force ni
physique ni mentale j'étais quand je
vivais là bas je me sentais aussi bas
que terre mais vraiment le plus à même
le sol n'était pas assez bas
contrairement à ce que je ressentais du
rire l âge aujourd'hui 24 ans 24 ans qui
était l'aînée de la famille
pour toi y est il ya toujours eu de la
maltraitance bien entendu il n'y a pas
une seule fois où
je n'ai même jamais il nous a jamais
pris dans ses bras ne nous a jamais dit
vous êtes mes enfants je vous aime c'est
ses seules infections entre parenthèses
si je peux dire c'étaient les cookies
nous donner et que ce soit physique ou
morale
tu as vécu commun d'aline comme ça dans
l'ag du temps de jeu
à mes 18 ans c'était la goutte de trop
j'ai décidé de partir suite encore une
énième ce qui s'est passé je devais
aller si j'étais en couple avec un
garçon d'accord et qui m'a empêché de
voir sauf qu'à un moment donné j'ai eu
marre c'était je voulais a peut être
libre en fait je leur ai dit clairement
à quel point elle peut être malheureux
pour que soient heureux
mais j'aurais dit écoutez je voulais pas
c'est pas grave moi dès maintenant je
prends mes affaires et je pars était
parti n'est plus jamais revenu le
lendemain matin ils m'ont appelée
m'insultant encore une fois de tous les
noms
l'existant ou inexistant sauf quand même
du coup mon ancien copain
et je leur ai dit je suis désolée mais
cette fois ci il ne paie pas en face de
moi cette fois ci je pouvais le répondre
lors disant que non du jeu font que
revenir je souffrais au début de cette
séparation parce que même si c'était la
maltraitance gêné que la beach et
cassettes cette maison nation mais une
fois une fois parti je me sentis si bien
c'était surtout le moment de ma vie où
en penser à eux je me sens bien parce
que je n'étais plus avec eux quand tu as
vu que l'affairé avait éclaté qu'est-ce
que tu t'es dit
son coup moi quand j'étais avec mes deux
frères au commissariat ce n'était pas ma
priorité on en entendait parler de lui
dans les journaux bon ça s'arrêtait là
mais quand on voyait vraiment que ça
prenait de l'ampleur je me suis là au
moins les gens vont peut-être agir en
temps ça nous on passe à mes frères et
soeurs n'ont pensé aussi peut-être au
futur ou aux enfants aussi qu'ils
subissent et on convoque s'empare
lourdement dans les médias vous vous
c'est quand même un cap très
particulière on espère aussi que ça fait
réagir les associations les écoles ou
même autres qu'ils puissent voir que
nous pendant deux longues longues fois
où on a prévenu il ya rien eu par
derrière qu'il soit centre social ou
même moi quand j'étais encore au lycée
peut-être que là ça me l'a fait réagir
les ans la wii là il ya vraiment un cas
alors il a peut-être ailleurs d'accord
alors mag a dit merci d'être avec nous
c'était à tante maternelle des enfants
on voulait absolument avoir votre
témoignage ce soir magali
donc poster est la maman de brian et 2
et de rudy vous avez vous saviez
détecter quelque chose ou pas du tout
détecté quelque chose que l'on dira je
voyais la maison je voyais la maison
sale oui ça je pourrais te nuire
personnellement car plus d'une fois en
fait en allant là-bas le nom des fois où
j'ai proposé mon aide en lui disant tu
veux de l'aide pour la maison tu veux de
l'aide pour les enfants ç'a toujours été
déçu je vais proposer de prendre l'une
des petites à la maison pour dormir la
nuit ça a été un refus également
d'accord alors oui on a vu on a toujours
essayé de trouver comment dire des
solutions de l'aider mais à un moment
donné c'était plus possible c'était mais
comment comment vivez les enfants quand
vous alliez là bas vous voyez qu'il y
avait un problème qu'ils étaient
malheureux ils ont essayé de vous parler
un moment pas du nom ils ont jamais si
jamais parlé malheureusement c'est s'est
jamais comme j'ai dit à brian au
téléphone puis d'une fois assesseurs
plus d'une fois en leur disant je ce que
j'ai pas compris c'est que j'aurais aimé
justement gens nous voir car moi
j'habite pas sur lens j'habite sur sur
près de bapaume donc en fait mon erreur
a été toujours d'appeler avant de venir
que ça car robin avec la route tout ça
je voulais pas non plus faire des heures
de route justement donc donc quand quand
vos parents savaient qu'avec quelqu'un
qui venait à changer d'attitude il
faisait des choses spéciales benjamin
ctb ça dépend des tout simplement des
personnes comme les quantités votre
temps par exemple quand c'est énorme a
gagné s'arranger pour puisque peut-être
qui se disait qu'elle allait dire
quelque chose sinon comme elle
connaissait bien et système instant de
social tout ça l'aurait pu manger si par
contre il y avait des amis certains
membres de la famille aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne parlent pas ou qui parle très peu
je savais qu'il n'allait rien dire du
moins jusque jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'était carte blanchi il faisait ce
qu'il voulait que ce soit devant jean
lamy qui a témoigné hier que ce soit
devant certaines personnes de la famille
mais il savait acquis qu'ils pouvaient
qui pouvait montrer sagan et magali donc
hissé le nécessaire pour que rien de
rien ne transparaît voilà trente ans
j'arrivais les petites et échanger
attaché mais voilà attaché on me dit va
le regarde juste un dessin animé way
elles font juste la sieste vous voyez
les deux petites attaches et ouais je
les ai vues clairement je les ai vus oui
mais c'était toujours elles font la
sieste alors on regarde juste un dessin
animé et quand les soeurs a débuté gg
j'ai parlé je lui ai demandé où dans les
enfants vous l'avez eue voilà quand
l'histoire éclatez vous avez eu votre
soeur je les ai vus vous l'avez vu alors
je les ai vus plus vous avez de jeu
revient poser cette question je lui dis
qu'on le dit où dorment les petites elle
m'a juré en me regardant droit dans les
yeux elles dorment dans leur lit j'ai
fait d'accord je vais essayer de te
croire c'est ma nièce qui deux jours
plus tard m'a appelé en larmes matthew j
-l monde elle m'a clairement dit non
les films ne dorment pas dans leur lit
elles dorment attaché dans les chaises
elles dorment dans leurs excréments et
là franchement mon sens il abrite où tu
fais là c'est pas possible je fais non
c'est c'est hors de question que je
laisse rsa souffert donc les petites
sont placés pour leur sécurité et
maintenant on va tout faire pour leur
part vous l'avez rappelé votre souris et
hiboux a je crois aussi que je vous
l'avais dit je lui ai tout dit que ce
qu'elle a fait et
juste et noble inhumain que moi qui suis
maman jamais je pourrais faire ça à mon
enfant c'est impensable que des enfants
jouent chute oui attaché comme ça jamais
c'est pas possible et elle vous a dit
quoi elle a continué à nier nier non sa
réponse et j'avais pas le choix
en quoi tu n'avais pas le choix en fait
vous l'avez parler des violences aussi
oui le v10 quoi on s'engage envers rudy
envers moi c'était que à ses yeux tout
est faux ah oui après ça je peux pas en
témoigner parce que bien sûr je suis en
moi ne le faisait pas elle c'est comme
brian dit elle servait de vent qui lui
sert et devant qui surtout ne pas le
faire d'accord et moi qui ai grandi
dedans elle savait très bien que
j'aurais réagi tout de suite donc à vous
a dit que sa cdc des bêtises c'est ça le
dit ça on y est donc vous a dit marianne
et érudit 10 dès maintenant clairement
oui quand vous avez vous avez vous avez
eu votre beau frère aussi ou pas du tout
le mari vous avez eu son mari non son
mari non je n'ai pas eu au téléphone
quand vous entendent y avait que nous
avons assez bien et avait bon à prester
détention de familiale quoi pas à grand
chose mais mais bon ça n'avait pas de
nom pas de croix se dispute à se taper
dessus vous y avez vous y avez cru ou
pas quand on tire le moment j'ai pas
fais pas du tout vous êtes bien c'est
pas possible je la vois pas faire ça
voilà vraiment clairement si vraiment je
me suis dit non c'est pas possible c'est
quand ma nièce m'a appelé m'a
effectivement avoué que les petits
dorment comme ça j'ai dit ok tout est
vrai donc là aujourd'hui vous y croyez
j'y crois mais c'est juste pas possible
de voir ça c'est quand on dit de la
maison de l'horreur pour vous on avait
vu le procureur adam factice c'est pas
vraiment la maison de l'horreur pour
vous c'était vraiment la maison de
l'horreur ouais quand je vois certaines
scènes je vois mes nièces attaché donc
oui c'est une horreur de faire ça cet
enfant le mot et est encore trop faible
la maison alors
ce qui va suivre
quand même très préoccupante puisque
vous lisez un enfer et puis
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce que vous
avez même été agressé j'ai été à l'as
effectivement pourquoi pas requis par
qui un jeune homme je ne connais pas
dans la vie je suis aide à la personne
d'accord donc je me déplace chez mes
clients pour les aider dans leur vie
quotidienne dans leur ménage dans mon
tout est en fait le soir je finisse à
ses heures ce jour-là c'était mercredi
dernier je suis ici à 16h et j'aurais
entamé le sort pour 10 à 18 heures donc
pour moi j'avais des heures de battement
je me suis dit je vais aller juste au
magasin me chercher un petit café glacé
à chaud donc je rentre dans le magasin
et déjà je je ressens des regards et je
me suis dit non c'est dans ta tête c'est
pas possible c'est dans ta tête je passe
à la caisse je paye limite la caissière
voulez mais j'étais là mais la monnaie
clairement la figure je me suis dit bon
c'est pas grave parce qu'elles savent et
ils ont dû ça tu vois qu'on est serre ça
je le reconnais mais moi je le sais puis
dans le voilà peut-être tout les gens le
savent vous êtes mois la voilà c'est
possible et je me suis bon c'est pas
grave ok est en fait arrivé sur le
parking géant temps derrière moi une
personne hurler on te retrouvera
excusez-moi des mots on te retrouvera
grosse [ __ ] on sera à plusieurs mais
on va te crever
et là franchement bas il n'y a plus rien
qui va à ce qu'on s'est dit mais j'y
suis pour rien moi dans cette histoire
c'est pas moi qui ai fait ça
moi je me bats justement pour protéger
les enfants et là tout de suite on pense
à son propre enfant mais s'il aurait été
avec moi s'en est extrait c'est quoi en
fait je suis car moi mon rôle c'est
aussi protéger mon petit garçon donc je
me dis mais ça se serait passé comment
donc depuis ce temps là ben non c'est
sûr plus gros gains sont et le regard
des gens qui voient là c'est le regard
des gens c'est une illusion il faisant
valley pense que vous êtes aussi
responsable de ce qui s'est passé
donc aujourd'hui vous vivez en enfer
ben c'est simple c'est je travaille plus
ah oui j'ai arrêté de travailler je suis
en arrêt je sais sous médication
pourquoi vraiment vous êtes ça va pas
ggg un suivi psychologique
car justement c'est pour eux comme le
dit maxime enlevé mon sentiment de
culpabilité
parce que ben justement j'ai pas j'ai
pas pu agir pour les protéger mais ça
mais c'est s'est passé l'eau c'est le
regard des autres qui fait que
aujourd'hui vous vous dites j'aurais dû
agir non c'est même pas le regard des
autres ça c'est moi c'était mon devoir
de tentes
cessé mes neveux et nièces c'était si
mon devoir de les protéger je suis maman
oui mais je suis aussi tentes et ça j'ai
pas pu j'ai pas su et ça je m'en
voudrais jusqu'à la fin de ma vie mais
comment vous auriez pu faire parce que
si personne ne vous disais si je sais
pas je sais pas comme j'ai dit à brian
comme j'ai dû à un rude il je sais pas
j'aurais dû voir
même si on m'a caché je ne serait ce
qu'un tout petit détail peut-être mort
est mis sur la voie car j'ai j'ai vécu
en fait tout ce qui est à nettoyer tout
ça j'ai vécu
j'ai vécu j'ai pas dire la maltraitance
car j'étais trop petit pour ce pour
connaître sa
mêlée famille un peu déchiré tout ça
j'aurais pu mais là un tel drame qui se
joue dans votre famille aujourd'hui vous
dites que votre vie ne sera plus jamais
la même tiens on sera plus jamais la
même vous avez des enfants de quel âge
j'ai un garçon de 16 ans 16 ans vous en
parlait tous les deux on en a parlé
qu'est ce qui vous dit votre garçon de
16 ans il comprend pas comment sa tante
a pu faire ça ouais que c'est plus c'est
plus un ses cousines lui manque
car malgré qu'ils ne les voyait pas
souvent certes une soirée ça reste sa
famille nation que maintenant même mon
fils a peur pour moi je sors
votre votre soeur vous pensez qu'elle a
été influencé par son mari parce que
tout non non alors non elle est non
c'est pas c'est pas du tout ça pour ses
quais bas c'est pas censé pas son
caractère ça elle sait pas influencer
donc vous pensez à un autre que celle
qui s'est elle qualifiée qui était le
ch'ti bon là géré à dire là ménez oui
mais mais c'est quelqu'un de cas du
caractère et a du caractère donc c'est
pas si elle n'était pas sous influence
non du tout bryant et ça c'est du show
complètement d'accord allez pense que
c'est qui qui parce que c'est vrai que
on se dit souvent comment démarre une
histoire pareille vous qui nous
regardent et soir en direct il est 21h
en oeuvre on se dit comment démarrer une
histoire pareille il y en a bien un qui
est le moteur vraiment et qui dit voilà
c'est passé pas une histoire normal pour
toi c'est et qui le moteur match
celui-là qui a commencé par vraiment les
coûts et les insultes ça a été mon père
lui c'est lui qui a vraiment commencé il
se prenait un peu pour l'homme de la
maison d'accord lui il affirmé et ma
mère a suivi a suivi dans cette
continuité la noc aller comme ça
aujourd'hui j'ai jamais vu mon père tapé
ma mère mais j'ai déjà vu ma mère tapé
mon père ça c'est une certitude donc
aujourd'hui le j'ai pensé que votre mère
aussi lui lui disais il faut que tu sois
plus dur il faut ou pas du tout non pas
du tout au contraire j'ai déjà vu mais
comme je vous ai dit ma mère tapé mon
père c'est mon père aussi mais jeudi une
question de mettre les enfants dehors
c'est lui qui prenait la décision et il
a appuyé sur sur ma mère m'a amusé
pression tout simplement pour que avec
lui elles nous mettent eux mais ils nous
mettent tous les dehors tout simplement
alors magali témoignage fait énormément
parler vraiment les gens de son très
triste pour vous aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que vous allez dire à qui est ce que
vous avez reparlé à votre soeur est ce
que vous allez essayer de la raisonner
ou est-ce que vous allez couper
complètement avec gégé coupe
complètement les points d'accord vous ne
voulez plus je ne veux plus jamais
entendre parler d'elle clairement ce
n'est plus la peine qu elle vous envoie
un message j'ai reçu un message d'elle
il ya deux jours en me disant qu'elle
était désolée pour mon agression
que elle ne comprenait pas et qu'elle
m'aimait
mais non c'est pas moi que tu dois des
excuses
oui je viens d'en faire mais tes enfants
ont vécu un enfer bien pire que le mien
franchement et sérieux que tu dois
m'excuser à auprès de moi donc pour vous
c'est terminé c'est terminé
rudy a demandé la garde de deux enfin
bryant a demandé la garde de ses frères
et soeurs
j'ai été voir plusieurs personnes de ma
famille quand il y en a qui sont
certains parrains et marraines on a
trouvé des solutions dont magali pour on
va essayer de voir maintenant avec le
juge on va essayer de faire sortir le
plus d'enfants possibles plus vite
possible
aujourd'hui on sait que ça sera pas
facile puisque maintenant les enfants
essayent de se reconstruire donc le ch
et que tous les juges nous nous
donnerons pas cette confiance tout de
suite moi en tout cas je vais je vais
tout faire pour les centres ad-hoc comme
j'ai dis leur donner tout l'amour qu'ils
n'ont jamais eue alors faire construire
à reconstruire du moins une vie normale
aujourd'hui on fera tout notre possible
pour que les enfants soient en sécurité
mais surtout prudents dans leurs bras
alors vos parents seront jugés en
janvier pour le moment ils risqueraient
deux ans de prison et 30 mille euros
damende magali pour vous c'est c'est
quoi ces
deux ans oui non
on vous sait si
je comprends pas qu'on donne deux ans
pour ça et attendez c'est le maximum et
maximum oui eh ben dis donc tu en voilà
si monsieur le procureur à nantes l'an
je sais pas vous aller témoigner vous
procès j'espère j'espère que je
rappelais oui je pense qu'ils allaient
être appelée vous avez ben y'a pas de
soucis sur le vrai pour le représenter
avec plaisir mais qu'elle ne s'attende
pas à ce que je témoigne en sa faveur
car ça n'arrivera pas
vous entendiez quand même bien avec
votre se retirer quand on a l'impression
vraiment que vous avez à mais c'est même
plus de la colère que j'ai c'est de la
rage
j'avais beaucoup entendu marianne rudy
c'est ça aussi il a fait qu'aujourd'hui
je les ai vu pleurer devant moi c'est
une chose horrible de voir ses neveux et
nièces en larmes ça m'a brisé
brisée puis jamais je vais les voir
pleurer à cause de jeu jamais
gilles donc ce sera je courre
aujourd'hui et ce qui est incroyable
c'est que quand on vous entend c'est une
maison de l'horreur vous êtes des
enfants martyrs et la justice ne retiens
rien de tout ça sera une question simple
à vous poser à tous les deux pourquoi
est-ce que vos parents sont protégés par
quelqu'un qu'est-ce qui se passe est ce
que la justice ne vous croient pas à
votre avis baj je pense comme ils disent
malheureusement ah j'oubliais j'ai
oublié de donner une information si
c'est que on a eu un coup de téléphone
du sud un des foyers de mon petit frère
de 6 ans et un médecin aujourd'hui
retrouvé des coûts retrouvez des coups
sur la tête fehr a aujourd'hui à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui encore il n'y en avait pas
donc il s'appuyer sur ça c'était leur
seule celle défense envers envers mes
parents aujourd'hui je suis choqué
normalement quand je vois un procureur
devant un accusé c'est le premier qui
qui veulent lui demandé la peine maximum
au juge aujourd'hui c'est le premier qui
les défend j'ai été atterré par ça
j'avais pris un coup au moral
aujourd'hui j'espère que maintenant le
médecin va pas donné toutes les preuves
aujourd'hui le médecin décrit des
maltraitances physiques des maltraitance
morale aussi puisque le pied aujourd'hui
violent ce qu'il y a il a été éduqué
dans la violence aujourd'hui nos sorties
que le petit avait jamais eu d'amour
aujourd'hui ils ont vu que jamais aucun
des parents n'a été au dentiste avec
aucun des enfants me il décrit une
maltraitance hygiénique aussi
aujourd'hui j'espère que toutes ces
preuves maintenant vont pas
pas fermer la bouche le procureur mais
lui donner raison d'ouvrir enfin les
yeux sur cette histoire puisque
aujourd'hui on a on n'a plus aucune
nouvelle de ce monsieur
aujourd'hui j'espère vraiment qu'ils et
qui sera encore du mal qui nous a faits
en disant ces paroles et
j'espère en tout cas que c'est que c'est
pas une personne comme ça qui sera là au
procès ce que j'ai bien peur pour notre
défense mais aussi pour tout l'est pour
tous les jeunes aujourd'hui qui sont
maltraités qui meurent sur leurs
couleurs leurs parents quand ils vont
ils se procurent j'ai un gros doute
qu'ils ont envie d'aller dénoncer leurs
parents ça je pense ça et aujourd'hui
des propos comme ça n'ont rien à faire
dans la justice française